- Children deserve like
detailed, detailed stop motion.
(relaxing music)
- As Kirsten Lapore,
our animation director,
put it at a Q and A,
it actually takes so much more effort
to make things be invisible
and effortless. (laughs)
- She's just so one of a kind, incredible.
- People think it takes a long time,
but like, it really takes
a long time. (laughs)
Like I would say,
I would say, a good reference for people
to think about is like, you know,
on an ideal day you might get,
you know, five,
maybe 10 seconds of footage.
And that's, like 10 seconds,
like that's a killer shoot day, you know,
one animator getting a ten second shot.
I think that's a good
sort of frame of reference
for how labor intensive it is,
but also how much it sort of pays off,
and you get the magic of the real objects.
- To play this character
who is heavily improvised
and then pair it with a process
that at once has to be filled with life,
like you have to be completely open
and also detail oriented,
down to the tiniest minutia,
in order to make Marcel
seem like his emotions
aren't just coming out of his mouth,
but that they're in his body.
That's a real honor.
It's like a real honor to pair,
to have one of my performances
paired with that type of art,
because there is so much
dedication to that intention
and that feels really good.
And it's actually something
we've tried for Marcel,
like in general, you know,
with our children's books,
all of the images in those
books are oil paintings
done by an oil painter named Amy Lind.
It's the same pairing that like,
I think the thinking
behind that has always been
that adults enjoy Marcel,
and children do too.
One thing people don't
often give to children
is like rich art, (laughs)
and like, we were like,
children deserve oil paintings.
They should just have
Marcel in them, you know?
Children deserve like detailed,
detailed stop motion.
(soft music playing)
- [Kirsten] Dean was very
involved in the whole process.
I mean, we, from the beginning,
like from the time the
audio play was ready
and all the voices were recorded,
we worked really closely together
story boarding everything.
So it was literally just us on Zoom,
basically back and forth,
just planning out every single shot
meticulously in board form.
So we had really our kind of whole roadmap
of of what to do once
we came to the studio
to actually shoot.
- [Dean] I mean, I think
your job as a director
is to prepare like a mad person
and be a total perfectionist
in the preparation.
And then, when you're actually on set,
be willing to throw
everything out the window
and just be an opportunist.
- [Kirsten] I mean, I was both on set
for the live action shoot,
really involved in every shot,
making sure we're sort of timing out.
Okay, how far are we moving Marcel?
You know, like in this very,
you know, like in five seconds,
how far would he move?
And I had kind of like a
little puppet on a stick
that I would approximate and
sort of like bop it along,
and then once we got to
the stop motion shoot,
then we sort of translated
that to that stage,
and Dean was with me
on every single stage.
We would pow-wow before each shot
and sort of like act
out like a lot of times,
like I would play Marcel,
he would play Connie,
and we would just kind
of play off of each other
and figure out,
Okay what is the performance
that we're really
going for here,
before we even go in to
talk to the animators.
And then once we game planned
and got on the same page, we would go in
and we would usually just
act it out for the animators,
sometimes also making a
reference video for them,
just so they have as much
information as possible
going into their shot,
because it takes them,
you know, a whole day,
sometimes two days, to do an entire shot.
So you wanna avoid retakes
as much as possible
because you don't want someone redoing
like two days of work where they've been
like painstakingly laboring
over a tiny puppet for,
you know, so many hours.
- [Jenny] When Dean is
dedicated to an aesthetic,
he does it all the way.
He is the first true artist
that I feel like I've ever met,
besides my own parents.
And then to see his work
replicated by this entire team,
you know, it was incredible
that there was just still a connection,
even with all of these other people there.
They all know who lives here.
They all, like, they all care.
- Even in the board phase,
like we had a lot of
fun coming up with like,
okay, what does one that
comes to mind is like,
you know, what is Connie's
little meal like that we cut to?
And it's like, okay,
it's a quarter with like
a generic goldfish cracker
and like a little piece
of like dust on top,
you know, for garnish.
Like those little things,
that was, there were,
there were tons of them,
tons of them, like,
and just finding what those
little jokey moments are,
that play with scale,
was I think one of the most
fun parts of the process,
also like down the line, once it came time
to design Marcel's family members,
like the extended community shells,
we brought in another friend of ours,
this woman Aco,
and we all kind of sat together
and went shopping to all these like,
crazy electronic stores
and like really specific
niche places all over LA,
like this shell store that was amazing.
And we just like collected tons of stuff
and then laid it out on the table,
and we just spent hours like,
designing little characters
out of the actual props.
And I think that's, you
know, something that you
wouldn't be able to
necessarily just figure out
off the top of your head
as you're even boarding.
Like we really try to be
as hands on as possible
in finding those actual
real objects, you know,
in the spirit of Marcel,
he's an actual real show.
That's one of the fun parts
about doing it in stop motion too.
Like that's what makes this movie so much
like tied to this specific medium,
like it really can't be done in CG,
like I feel like the thing
that makes it truly real
and using these actual
real objects like that,
that is sort of at the
heart of stop motion
and working with actual things.
(soft music playing)
- [Dean] You have to surrender yourself
to the current moment.
And this movie was a,
exercise in that,
because the whole point
was to try to make it feel
authentically spontaneous and documentary,
but obviously when you're
telling a story with stop motion,
live action hybrid, that is,
has all these things going on, you can't,
it's an illusion that that was
in any way spontaneous. (laughs)
- [Kirsten] There are really no films
that are shot like this.
I mean, with the exception of like,
Monkeybone a long time ago.
Even that isn't a great comp
because it's kind of like a bigger puppet.
So we really had nothing to go off of
and how to sort of figure out
how do we shoot this movie?
How do we make it work?
And how do we make it
really really naturalistic
and feel like, oh, Marcel was just,
we turned a video camera on
and we just captured him.
So that was, you know,
definitely a challenge.
There was a moment where
we were considering,
okay maybe we actually
shoot it in the house
and have the animators like
down on the floor, you know,
crouching like with the puppets,
maybe we control all the
lighting in the entire house
and like flag off all the windows.
So that was something we considered.
But in the end I think
that would be a little too
physically grueling for those animators
cuz houses aren't built like
stop motion sets, you know,
stop motion sets are
built very particularly
so we can get underneath them,
you can like tie things down,
really get access to
everything you need to
on that miniature stage.
So ultimately we ended
up going that direction
but a lot of other tests
of crazy camera heads
and recording, you know,
the cameras motion and
translating that to the stage.
There were so many things we played with
and then ultimately we figured,
okay we have to shoot this twice. (laughs)
And just sort of competent
in a more traditional way.
- [Dean] I felt very committed to
trying to make this as much
like a real documentary as possible.
And I'd never seen a quote
unquote documentary that actually
took its subject seriously
and treated them with dignity.
And so it was kind of always a
question of, well, how do we,
how do we solve these problems?
How does Marcel get, you know,
to his stockpile or whatever?
How does he get from one room
to another quickly while also
you know, trying to keep it
within the realm of possibility
because with an animated
character, you know,
you could make him fly or whatever.
You're not bound by those live
action rules, but it, so I,
I think we were constantly
trying to gut check ourselves
against what a real documentary
would look like and do.
- [Jenny] In movies for
children, there will be sorrow
there will be loneliness or fear
but this is a movie for everyone.
And I think one thing that I try to do
not just as an artist,
but as a person is to soothe
the child that remains inside of me.
And I've also learned
that now as a parent that,
through your art
and through your behavior
with other people,
you can start to kind of like,
if you want to sort of re-parent yourself.
And a lot of that has to do
with allowing for a big
variety of emotions to
be held inside of even
the smallest individual.
And you know, for it's like,
it would be easy to make
Marcel like, just be cute.
But instead I think what Dean
and I really wanted to do,
and we were like, well,
when it comes down to it,
when we're alone as Dean and Jenny, what,
what makes us feel good?
What makes us feel satiated is,
putting as many emotions
as possible into one place.
(soft music playing)